faster TD jakes inspires millions around
the world with his empowering sermons
easily offended will never be mighty you
can't be mighty and penny at the sage I
like that TD jakes presides over
congregation of more than 30,000 in
Dallas Texas and he has counseled former
presidents Barack Obama Bill Clinton and
George W Bush known as Bishop Jake's he
just announced a new foundation this
morning the TD jakes foundation will
offer job training in classes in science
technology engineering arts and math
known as steam Bishop Jake's is here for
his first TV interview about the
foundation I want to talk about that of
course but I have to talk to you about
Kobe Bryant when I heard you were on
today I was so excited because I find
myself and so many people have been hit
by this in a way that we hadn't expected
even those who didn't know him or taking
this very hard and trying to sort this
out why is it hitting us this way do you
think you know do you feel this - oh I
absolutely feel it I absolutely feel
like I had to stop watching it every
time I see it I get real sad like it's
my family member and I'm not really a
big sports guy yeah but but you have to
recognize that people like him have
become the gladiators of our era these
football players and basketball players
who reach that height of celebrity
status and I also think that his his
failures and his flaws add to the
affection of America because his people
say he was not a perfect man the reality
is we like people who are human enough
to have flaws and hero enough to
overcome them and we watched him
overcome them so we were rooting for him
to go on to his legacy yeah as he was
starting a new chapter in his life
that also makes her and his daughter was
with and his daughter was with him and
that's the part that rips my chest out
yes his daughters and the photographs of
him and his daughter it just it's like
so hard so it's so shocking and it's so
sudden it's a moment when people if
they're people of faith might say maybe
I'm not so faithful anymore this
happened well you know
fewer rooted and grounded in your faith
you use your faith to get through the
darkness rather than using the darkness
to challenge your faith so it depends on
your level of faith people who are just
lightly in faith then it blows it to
smithereens but people who are rooted
and grounded we've seen death we've seen
hard times we've seen tragedy and it is
our faith that gives us the resilience
to go on the other thing that I said
off-camera that I think it's important
what can we do we can't change the
situation but what we can do is have a
little closer the people in our lives
that we love not take them for granted
take the time out of our busy schedule
to really get back focused on what
matters the people in your life the
people that you care about and to not
take them for granted because every
moment is a precious moment yeah the
tragedy becomes for the family how did
that how did they get through it is
being described as iconic status did he
have that before I think that he did to
a degree but certainly when I whenever
we know that we can't get anymore the
value of anything goes up yeah you're
here to talk about something very
exciting that yeah when I first saw it
Bishop Jake's I thought it was a typo
where they were saying Steve Jim yes I
thought don't they mean stem no tell us
why you're so excited well the reason
that we're focused their several agendas
that were focusing on I started the
foundation first of all because I
recognized that whoever succeeds me as
the pastor of the church may not care
about the community issues that I care
about so I wanted to sequester them into
the foundation so that I would have
legacy and continuation and so that we
could really focus on making a
difference in life States tim is a very
important part of the feature we're at
eight percent unemployment in
african-american community we are
projected to be at twenty percent
unemployment if nobody does anything to
well we're starting on all levels
teaching about stem programs and we're
using the arts as a enticement
interesting why is it important for you
to include the arts what is the latest
stats say that the arts calls inner-city
kids to become interested in technology
ah interesting you see yeah sure so it's
at a very very effective way maybe I
want to be a producer maybe I want to do
something in film and so I start fooling
around on the computer trying they
headed but it is a gateway through which
we can begin to discover the amazing
worlds of techno so we were looking at
the numbers this morning and blacks and
Hispanics are very underrepresented in
STEM 9 and 7% respectively in that
workforce how does your foundation
planet turn those numbers around and
what success well well first of all it's
not a conversation that's talked about
enough on a grassroots level in our
community so that awareness is going to
be important talking about there are
great programs out here that CEOs have
committed dollars in funds to reach
those demographics that are underserved
because there are actually opportunities
not casualties but those programs and
services that exist our community
doesn't hear about them so I want to
connect the service providers with the
people who are in need because I have
one foot in the corporate world and one
foot in the community in a very unique
way so I know how to communicate to the
community ways and concepts that are
pre-existing and help them to facilitate
their service but the foundation doesn't
stop with staying that also includes
workforce housing because in most of our
metropolitan major city areas the cost
of living has imagine being a police
officer or a nurse who is serving a city
you can't afford to live in we have to
fix that and bring the price of living
down for the workforce people in our
cities and so that they can make a good
way every age and not drive an hour and
a half to get it's a great more or lower
the rents time it's a great mission
great mission pastor TD jakes thank you